our first performance and we were all
doing a circle on stage that's sort of
like a bonding circle before we went on
and our stage manager very commonly was
like just so you all know there are
protesters outside kind of you know
accosting some of the people who are
trying to get into the theater but
people are undeterred and they're
heading inside and they're excited to
see it and I think it was obviously
disappointing and scary but also really
galvanizing and reminded us all how
urgent this particular story is and
there's been lots of little things along
the way that have been sort of the
universe letting us all know that this
is really the story to be telling at
this current moment